and then when he died we lived a lie
because we couldn't tell people why he
died
silence Denise and Colin felt they
needed to maintain after their son Lee
died with HIV he contracted at age four
after unknowingly being given
contaminated blood products
it's hard to look at somebody it's so
happy
he died at just 10 years old 30 years
later his parents heard the news they'd
been waiting for
I'm recommending further interim
compensation payments
to recognize the deaths of people who
have so far gone unrecognized
as I believe this is necessary to
alleviate immediate suffering especially
for the children of victims of the
infected blood Scandal and bereaved
parents
it's what we've always known but we've
never been able to get this information
out and it
he should have been acknowledged a long
time ago I'm for us to have him
for him to be acknowledged now is is
just
huge huge for us
he lost his life
and he shouldn't have he should have
still be here really
a sense of validation that some families
still don't have Nikki died after
receiving contaminated blood because his
widow received an interim payment to
acknowledge her loss last year his
mother Rosemary will not
we've nursed our children
uh we've watched him die
for us to say there's no money really
that can compensate for that but it's
just recognition of of our pain and our
suffering that we we're looking for
it's the people in here they will look
to
these recommendations will be picked up
again when Parliament returns to sitting
on April the 17th for now the government
reiterates that this Scandal should
never have happened it's for the cabinet
office to decide whether to act on these
findings
Denise and Colin say it would mean their
son's suffering and their pain have
finally been understood ashenharanak Sky
News